voici joaquín guzmán zohra dit el chapo
ce qui veut dire le petit trapu au
moment de la sentence prison à vie plus
30 ans pour usage d'armes automatiques
le procureur est satisfait pour la
première fois depuis son extradition en
2017 el chapo a pris la parole sa jeune
épouse emma coronel était dans la salle
d'audience il s'est plaint d'avoir été
torturée physiquement psychologiquement
et mentalement 24 heures par jour
pendant sa détention justice n'a pas été
rendue at il ajouté description la peau
douce man répondait à 17 chefs
d'accusation pour trafic de cocaïne
complot pour meurtre et blanchiment
d'argent
c'est un personnage mythique parti de
rien comme cueilleurs de cannabis il a
pris la tête du plus puissant cartel du
mexique
il aurait exporté aux états unis plus de
1200 tonnes de cocaïne pendant un quart
de siècle les nombreux témoins au procès
dans des ex-membres de son cartel de
sinaloa ont fait le portrait d'un chef
sanguinaire qui aurait assassiné de sa
main au moins 26 personnes
après les avoir parfois torturés c'est
aussi le roi de l'évasion
une première fois en 2001 il s'échappe
de la prison la plus sécuritaire du
mexique dans une cargaison de linge sale
grâce à des complicités dans le
personnel sa deuxième évasion est encore
plus spectaculaire
il s'enfuit par un trou creusé sous sa
toilette et un tunnel d'un kilomètre et
demi
éclairez climatisée est pourvu d'une
moto sur rails jusqu'à cette maison dans
la campagne
de la bonne matière pour télésérie cette
fois personne n'arrêtera même s'il fera
appel joaquín guzmán zohra 62 ans finira
probablement séjour dans ce pénitencier
du colorado à sécurité vraiment maximum
en compagnie des pires criminels des
états unis dans l' isolement le plus
complet jean michel leprince sera du
canada montréal